Madame la Premier ministre, dans le Finistère, nous en avons connu des tempêtes.
Pour tous, celle qui vient de dévaster la pointe de la Bretagne
et le nord-ouest de la France avait un nom, Ciaran.
Pour nous, habitants de la 8e circonscription du Finistère,
il restera un autre prénom, un autre nom et surtout un visage associé à cette tempête.
Celui de Frédéric Despaux, agent d'Enedis, décédé
en travaillant à rétablir l'électricité pour des milliers de Bretons.
Il avait 46 ans et trois enfants.
Originaire de Auch, il venait dans le cadre de la force d'intervention rapide
avec de nombreux agents Enédis pour réparer
le réseau électrique complètement dévasté.
Je souhaite au nom des habitants de ma circonscription,
lui rendre hommage ainsi qu'à sa famille.
Son sens du devoir nous honore.
Je veux aussi remercier et surtout féliciter
le préfet du Finistère et ses services,
tous les agents publics et tous les élus des collectivités locales,
les forces de l'ordre, les pompiers et la sécurité civile, ainsi que les citoyens
qui ont fait preuve d'une solidarité incroyable.
Alors si cette crise a été bien anticipée et bien gérée, elle nous interroge.
Nous savons le dérèglement climatique
ne va qu'accentuer ces catastrophes.
Nous sommes devenus dépendants aux télécommunications et
la coupure totale de tous les réseaux mobiles et filaires
a été particulièrement mal vécue par tous
les habitants, élus et forces de l'ordre.
Il est primordial d'en tirer les leçons pour améliorer notre anticipation
et protéger la population.
Dans la continuité du déplacement de Jean-Noël Barrot,
que je remercie pour son soutien, je souhaite m'adresser
à madame la Première ministre.
Comment l'Etat compte-t-il améliorer son plan de gestion de crise
et d'adaptation pour améliorer la résilience des
réseaux et leur capacité à rester opérationnel ?